okay look at this watch this looks like
a normal Smartwatch right it's got a big
circular AMOLED display it's 15
millimeters thick it's about the same
size as an Apple Watch Ultra I think
most people would never suspect a thing
until you open the lid and there's
literal earbuds inside so this is
huawei's watch buds it's pretty much
exactly what it sounds like you've got a
fully functioning smart watch but then
you can just pop out the earbuds and
jump on a phone call or listen to music
or do whatever you're gonna do it's
actually kind of clever now to put them
back they're actually magnetized to the
inside of the lid and charge from the
watch's battery and actually each earbud
is identical so you can put them back in
whatever order you want and when they're
actually in your ears you do a nod
gesture and they can calibrate in space
which one's the right and the Left
Channel
now this is purely convenience play like
these are tiny earbuds they don't sound
amazing the noise cancellation barely
works and they only have a three hour
battery life and they take the watch's
battery life down from two weeks to
about three days but also like I don't
know it's kind of sick you'd never lose
your earbuds case again